[Música]
el próximo 26 de septiembre será el día
de la reapertura de las fronteras y la
normalización total de las relaciones
bilaterales entre colombia y venezuela
tras el anuncio de los presidentes de
ambos países vamos a analizar por
supuesto ya este anuncio final con una
fecha tan esperada el 26 de septiembre
vamos a salvar a ronald rodríguez el es
investigador del observatorio de
venezuela de la universidad del rosario
ronald gusto tenerlo con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 finalmente
como ya lo estábamos hablando entonces
tenemos esta fecha de la reapertura de
las fronteras también se espera que ese
día pues ya también se reanuden los
vuelos comerciales tan esperados por la
población tanto venezolana como
colombiana y pues hablemos entonces del
impacto monetario el impacto comercial
que va a tener por supuesto esta
reapertura
buen día raúl pues en efecto la apertura
de la frontera pues podría llegar a
significar para el estado colombiano y
para el estado venezolano un intercambio
que este año podría cerrar alrededor de
los mil millones de dólares recordemos
que el año pasado a pesar de los cierres
y las dinámicas hoy el comercio
bilateral tiene que subir hasta la
frontera entre la guajira y el estado
zulia cerró el año pasado en 391
millones de dólares este año si se abre
la frontera podríamos llegar a los 1000
se dice según la la cámara de comercio
colombo venezolana la cual dirigía hasta
hace muy poco el ministro y profesor
germán umaña que en el primer semestre
llegamos a un intercambio comercial de
los 400 millones de dólares es decir ya
viene creciendo si se mantuviera este
ritmo de crecimiento este año
cerraríamos en los 800 mil pero si se
abre la frontera y se puede aprovechar
las fiestas del final del año el
intercambio comercial que ellas producen
podríamos llegar a los mil millones de
dólares entre los dos países eso le
quería preguntar al digamos aterrizamos
un poco esta idea realmente este 26 de
septiembre podemos esperar
reapertura total de la frontera del
comercio y también de los vuelos
comerciales o será algo más
paulatino como para tener ya el
restablecimiento total y como digamos
los gobiernos ya pudieron llegar hasta
este punto bueno eso es parte de una
negociación bastante compleja en el lado
venezolano en un poco de nerviosismo
particularmente algunos de los gremios
venezolanos sienten que si se abre la
frontera plenamente entre táchira y
norte de santander que es la frontera
que se encuentra un poco bloqueada
tendríamos algunas dificultades y en
esas dificultades ellos ven es
supuestamente en la invasión de su
mercado con productos colombianos
recordemos que la economía venezolana
todavía es una economía bastante frágil
que depende de una dolarización que se
hizo de facto y de hecho en la zona de
frontera la moneda que se suele utilizar
para los intercambios comerciales es el
peso colombiano hay unos nerviosismos el
gobernador del estado táchira ha dicho
que lo que va a ocurrir el 26 de
septiembre va a ser algo digamos lo
puramente simbólico no obstante pues si
hay un trabajo que ha venido adelantando
particularmente el profesor umaña el
ministro de comercio y de colombia que
ha venido trabajando este tema desde el
2020 yo de hecho tuve la oportunidad de
participar en reuniones en 2020 y este
año se han hecho varias reuniones en la
zona de frontera en las cuales los
gremios se han empezado a una dinámica
de diálogo para poder hacer este
comercio pero pues como muchas cosas en
venezuela por un lado tenemos al
presidente nicolás maduro diciendo que
se abre plenamente la frontera para el
paso de mercancías por el otro lado
tenemos al gobernador del estado táchira
donde dice que va a ser un poco más
simbólico y que se requiere coordinar
muchas cosas recordemos que venezuela se
retiró de la comunidad andina de
naciones de la can en 2016
en 2006 perdón y ese esa salida esa
denuncia del acuerdo tardó cinco años
por protocolos de salida hoy el comercio
bilateral entre colombia y venezuela
requiere unos parámetros mucho más
estrictos en materia comercial estamos
en el marco de
el comercio internacional pero todo el
andamiaje comercial que teníamos antes
no existe en este momento y
particularmente en el paso de transporte
colombia digamos que ha mejorado en
infraestructura en los últimos años
venezuela lamentablemente no lo ha hecho
y uno de los temas es cuál es el estado
de la infraestructura venezolana para
llevar productos desde la frontera hasta
el centro hasta caracas cuál es el
estado del parque automotriz cuántos
camiones del lado venezolano realmente
están adecuados para hacerlo y
particularmente un tema que del cual no
se ha hablado desde el cierre es el
pirataje terrestre que también puede
afectar el comercio bilateral eso le
quería decir ronald porque más allá
digamos de la infraestructura que pueda
tener venezuela digamos desde las zonas
fronterizas hasta el centro del país o
el norte del país mejor dicho dónde se
encuentra digamos caracas la capital
está el tema de seguridad que estos
productos en efecto si lleguen y no sean
víctimas de piratas de carretera o de
personas que pues hurten estos productos
para luego revenderlos y que pues este
comercio no se vea afectado pero más
allá del ámbito comercial rural yo
quisiera tocar un tema también muy y por
supuesto que estaban esperando todos los
ciudadanos venezolanos que se encuentran
en este lado de la frontera y también
los que se encuentran los colombianos
que se encuentran en venezuela y es este
digamos intercambio de personas en los
fueros comerciales también de las
fronteras cuál es el impacto social que
podría tener esta apertura de fronteras
desde iniciando el 26 de septiembre
bueno una de las particularidades de lo
que ha sucedido en estos años es que
hemos supeditado la población a pasar en
condiciones de irregularidad una parte
del cierre se debe a las dinámicas de
salud pública producto de la pandemia
pero lamentablemente la población
venezolana y la población colombiana que
hace el cruce de frontera que supeditada
a tener que pasar por las trochas en
algunos casos hay personas que logran
conseguir casi que un servicio vip y que
los lleva desde caracas hasta bogotá en
las condiciones de seguridad bastante
buenas pagando altísimos costos teniendo
que pasar por la frontera de forma
irregular pero esto lo que hace es
quitarle ese negocio
los actores criminales que se han
fortalecido durante estos años que una
persona puede hacer un vuelo desde
venezuela desde caracas hasta bogotá es
importante durante unos años estuvimos
tercerizando con panamá
muchos ciudadanos venezolanos incluso
han alimentado las dinámicas del
aeropuerto de cúcuta porque tenían que
pasar la frontera de forma irregular
llegar a cúcuta y de cúcuta hacia en el
enlace con panamá para ir a terceros
destinos ahora esto le permitiría que
pudiese viajar desde bogotá a terceros
destinos digamos que lo que tiene es un
carácter de humanización de las
condiciones de viaje porque lo que vimos
estos años es que la falta de diálogo
entre los dos gobiernos causó que los
ciudadanos tuvieran que pasar de forma
irregular por trochas claro exponiéndose
y esto se explica por el crecimiento de
organizaciones de trata de personas lo
cual pues es bastante crítico para
colombia y para venezuela pero también
el tráfico de migrantes el tener que
supeditarse a estos pagos en los en los
mercados ilegales fue una de las de las
situaciones que más afectó a la
población en ambos lados de la frontera
no solamente a los venezolanos los
colombianos que llegan a venezuela no
gana el increíble también como usted lo
decía bien usa un vuelo de caracas o
bogotá que pues podría estar alrededor
de una hora y media una hora y 40 de
vuelo máximo pues las personas que
tienen que ir hasta panamá para después
venir a bogotá o hasta méxico para ir a
votar algo totalmente absurdo siendo
pues un vuelo tan corto no o sea como
casi un vuelo que se puede hacer aquí
dentro dentro de colombia ronald de
hecho raúl en el 2019 traíamos
profesores para la cátedra venezuela la
universidad del rosario y la cas y
teníamos profesores a los cuales el
tiquete les costaba casi lo mismo que
viajar a europa claro haciendo en la
escala en panamá era una cosa ridícula y
en los tiempos de viaje eran
prácticamente insostenibles para
procesos académicos como éste